[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Mary is
with us she's in Seattle hey Mary
welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you Happy New Year happy New
Year how can we
help okay uh so I was an idiot um I was
in love with a a man that convinced me
to coign on a 2019 Jetta in the fall of
2021 um um I'm not in that relationship
anymore um but anyway uh last summer I
convinced him to turn the vehicle back
into the dealer basically voluntarily
repossess it he could not pay the um
payment on time and I was also helping
him and he made more than me um but
anyway so um Volkswagen hasn't said
hasn't sold the vehicle yet at auction
but when it's sold um of course we me
and him are going to be on the hook for
whatever is left on the
loan so I want to know um if there's
anything I can do he he does have a
settlement for Harley that he uh got in
an accident and uh wasn't his fault and
he's going to get uh compensated for
that I was also a co-signer on the
Harley because I was stupid um but that
bike has been paid off uh he's just
waiting for the settlement I'm wondering
can I put a lean on a settlement or what
can I do I I have text messages from him
saying that he will pay off the Jetta
but I don't trust that that's going to
happen it sounds like that's a correct
assessment to me um where was that
girl
yeah oh Mary I'm so sorry what a
horrible mess oh what a what a sad way
to learn a horrible lesson too isn't it
yeah how how old are you I'm 60 and he
was 43 so I had a little bit of the
share complex going on or something
there the share complex you're great
you're great okay so how much money how
much money do you have
uh how much money do I
have well I'm on baby step one I I'm
just starting now you don't have any
money I don't have any money I have
$3,000 in credit card debt that I have
uh consumer credit card what do you
make 61,000 a year okay what was owed on
the Jetta do you know 29,000 and change
okay all
right H all right let's just make up
some numbers for a second just to give
you an example all right let's pretend
that that Jedi when he turned it in was
worth 20 on the repo lot let's pretend
that it sells for
12 okay it might get 15 for it um but um
you know we could say
nine anyway so Le let's say there's a
$155,000 deficit when you're done right
mhm and they come to you as the
co-signer and they want
$115,000 well the first thing you tell
them is what you told me I have no
money right I don't have any money I got
$33,000 in credit card debt and I have
zero cash saved and I don't have any
money that's the first thing you tell
him which is also by the way the truth
and you can tell him where he is and
where his Harley account is and that he
is getting a settlement and that they
should get the money from
him okay um and help them get it from
him that's the best thing you can do if
that doesn't work and you and I are both
suspect it
won't
right then the good news is you can
usually settle a repossession deficit
for somewhere around 10 to 20 cents on
the dollar and so if it's 15,000 owed
$1500 to $3,000 will settle it oh yeah
okay so but if you get to that point
that means you're going to a have gotten
out of debt you're going to have built
up some a little bit of an emergency
fund of 5 or $110,000 or something
before they get around to bothering you
with this and then when they call and
bother you you say okay go after him and
they say well we tried and you say well
you ought to try again cuz I got no
money and uh then they come back at you
again then you say hey uh just want to
settle my part I don't want to settle
his
part so you can still go after him for
more if you want but I'll give you 1,500
for my
part mhm and start working with them and
you'll have to Josh all back and forth
with them and argue with them some but
you probably will get it for500 or
$2,000 $3,000 and then let them leave
his part there don't settle the whole
debt say I want I want the portion but I
need inwriting from you that the portion
of my name is settled in full that I owe
nothing that I owe nothing else and you
can go after him for whatever you
want right perfect okay that's a lot
better than I thought yeah you're you're
you're in better shape it's not going to
kill you here but you do have to go
ahead and get the rest of your money
straightened up yeah and then you you
just have a 3,000 in credit card debt is
there anything
else I own a house with my ex-husband
and we both pay half of the mortgage on
it and it's probably worth about 800,000
here in Seattle but we owe like 170 who
lives in
it um myself my two sons and it's a
there's a mother-in-law apartment so the
ex lives there too um but we're not
together or anything we just yeah we get
along it works for us and that was my
choice many years ago when we divorced
so wow okay all right well then yeah
you've got that asset you don't want
them attaching that asset so you do want
to settle this right right so you do
need to get the rest of your stuff under
control so you got a little cash built
up War chest before the war
comes yes yeah wow perfect well we're
usually talking to a a an a 24 year old
that did something like this but you can
still give anybody that's dating someone
the same warning never co-sign for
someone that never buy anything on debt
in any way or even co-own something with
someone you're not married to which
would you would you testify to that Miss
Mary I am I will preach it till to the
mountains absolutely I will never do
that and it doesn't matter how goodlook
you are and how goodlooking he is and
you know how much of a share complex you
want to have it's not worth it wow
that's a great testimony that's very
good you did you did a good job Mary
we're proud of you you'll be okay if you
need more help we're here to help you
okay thank you so much absolutely thank
thanks for calling in what's your old
quote Dave testimon is a wonderful thing
to have getting getting ones a pain in
the butt yeah that's what Mary just
experiened with her share complex oh
that's funny oh she's great that was a
fun way to end great but yeah the the
the whole co-signing thing man dangerous
stuff obviously there's proof dangerous
stuff if you need it uh create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way a budget for your life